>> Tucker: WE HAVE AN UPDATE
ON IAN SMITH, A NEW JERSEY GYM
OWNER WE INTRODUCED YOU TO WAS
BATTLING THE GOVERNOR OF THAT
STATE TO EARN A LIVING.
TRACE GALLAGHER HAS THE VERY
LATEST ON THAT.
>> THE OWNERS OF THE GYM IN
SOUTH JERSEY BOWED TO OPEN EVERY
DAY THIS WEEK REGARDLESS OF THE
CONSEQUENCES.
MONDAY THEY WERE GIVEN A
CITATION.
TUESDAY THEY WERE CITED AND A
GYM MEMBER WAS ARRESTED FOR
VIOLATING THE ORDER.
TODAY THE OWNERS, IAN SMITH AND
FRANK, WERE CHARGED WITH MAKING
A PUBLIC NUISANCE, AND IT GETS
WORSE.
A POLICE CAMERA IS NOW TAKING
PICTURES OF MEMBERS AS THEY
LEAVE THE GYM AND ARE
SOUTH JERSEY FOX AFFILIATES SAID
POLICE THEN FOLLOW THE MEMBERS
AND ISSUED THEM CITATIONS.
TODAY, GOVERNOR PHIL MURPHY WAS
ASKED ABOUT THE GYM, WATCH.
>> INSIDE, NO VENTILATION, CLOSE
CONTACT IS HARD NOT TO CRACK.
WE ARE NOT THERE YET ON INDOOR
DINING, DO WE WANT TO BE THERE?
WILL WE GET THERE, PLEASE GOD,
YES.
>> LATE TODAY THE OWNERS OF THE
GYM RELEASED A STATEMENT
CLAIMING 45 MINUTES AFTER THE
GOVERNOR SPOKE THE TOILETS IN
THE GYM STARTED BACK FLOWING
SEWAGE AND THE GYM HAD TO SHUT
DOWN FOR THE DAY.